هو ليس الاتهام الاول الذي يواجههم محمد
رمضان
باستفزاز جمهوره لكن هذه المره كان الامر
اكثر جدلا من اي مره سابقه فمع صوره نشرها
النجمه المصري وطبعا شاهد هالجميع في
طائره الخاصه بجانب رزم من الدولارات اصبح
رمضان قبل ايام حديث مواقع التواصل ووسائل
الاعلام ايضا الامر تجاوز تهمه الاستفزاز
الطبيب المصري الشهير جمال شعبان طالب
رمضان بان يدفع من هذه المبالغ جزءا لاجل
الفقراء المرضى تعليق الطبيب وجد اذنا
صاغيا من رمضان الذي اجتمع بالطبيب ووعده
بدعم المرضى والعمل الخيري ليظهر سويا
بصوره واحده كل هذا لم ينفع رمضان الذي
تعرض للسخريه كبيره من الفنان خالد سرحان
ليرد رمضان بسخريه مماثله فيما طالبت
مشاهدينا امال عبد الحميد عضو لجنه
الموازنه بالبرلمان بمراجعه الضرائب التي
يتم تحص
يلها على العموم احنا سنستعرض معكم سويه
ومع الزميله الزميل لميس لميس معنا راح
نستعمل نستعرض هذا الجدل وما الذي دار
شكرا لكما
قبل اعوام بدات تهمه الاستفزاز تلاحق محمد
رمضان فمن ينسى تلك الصوره
الشهيره مع الكابتن الطيار الراحل اشرف
ابو اليسر الذي اقيل على اثرها من عمله
قبل ان يتوفى محمد رمضان كان على موعد مع
تهمه الاستفزاز مجددا بعد ذلك بسنوات حين
نزل الى شوارع الاسكندريه ردا على
الرافدين لاقامه حفله في المدينه ليتجول
فيها مؤكدا حبا اسلا ايضا كان الاستفزاز
مرافقا لتصرفات رمضان لا سيما في لحظات
استعراض سيارته الجديده وهو الامر الذي
عاده ما يكرره رمضان كلما اقتنى سياره
رمضان عرف بصوره الغريبه فمثلا ينظف
اسناننا بمعجون من الذهب كذلك فهو معروف
بنشر منشورات فيسبوكيه تتحدث عن شخصه
وكفاحه وانه لو عاد به الزمن لفعل نفس
الاشياء
افعلها دوما
وان تجاوز رمضان تهمه استفزاز الجمهور
فكيف يتجاوز استفزاز زملاء المهنه خصوصا
وانه دائما ما يقول انه النمبر وان وهو
الامر الذي يرفضه الوسط الفني عموما سال
الناس في مصر هل اظهار الثراء امام الناس
مقبول ام مرفوض بمعنى اخر هل تقول فلوسي
وانا حر فيها ام تشعر بالاخرين نتابع
الاجابات
بحل البلد ده اللي احنا فيه متهيالي مرفوض
قوي يعني وبعدين انا ابين ليه للناس ان
انا في في عندي صرائع جامد زياده عن
اللزوم كده وغيري كتير قوي قوي ومحتاج معك
فلوس ومرتاح وكويس اعيش حياتك ان انت
تظهرها قدام الناس بقى بمنظر كدهوت يعني
بتتباع انت كده بتبقى بتتباها قوي وعايز
تبين للناس ان انت معك فلوس وبس انما يعني
بتكهر ناس تانيه في حياتها لازم يكون في
مراعاه لشعار للاخرين ولازم يكون في تقدير
للناس برده اللي هي في الشارع مثلا معهاش
فلوس معهاش تاكل اصلا
[موسيقى]
الماده
الظاهر بيها قدام الناس قدام الفقير طبعا
بيبقى محتاج غصب عنه طبعا ايه بيبقى محتاج
يعني ده يبقى محتاج فلوسي اللي هو يصرف
واللي معاه فلوس بيتباع بيها لا طبعا امر
مرفوض عشان المراعاه طبعا الشعور الاخرين
اللي هم طبعا الناس اللي مفيش اصلا
امكانيه اي حاجه في البلد ممكن يعمل كده
بس يعني من غير ما حد ما يعرف زكاه نتبرع
نساعدهم بطريقه ما حدش مش ملحوظه ما حدش
عارف دي حاجه بيننا وبين ربنا يعني
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا من القاهره استاذ امراض القلب
وعميد معهد القلب السابق الدكتور جمال
شعبان اهلا بك دكتور معنا في صباح العربيه
اهلا بحضرتك وصباح جميل سعيد من القاهره
لاهل العربيه ولكل قلوب العرب وتمنياتي
لكل القلوب العرب ان تكون بصحه وسلامه ان
شاء الله طيب الدكتور خلينا نبدا لو حبذا
لو تضعنا في سوره تفاصيل الاحداث اللي جرت
والحديث اللي جرى بينك وما بين الفنان
محمد رمضان
يعني هو قبل الحديث انا كنت دايما برضو
بنتقد هذا الاسلوب بتاعه بس اسلوبي يعني
ما كانش يعني بيتخطى حدود اللياقه يعني
انا اهتم جدا ان انت لما تواجه نقد
الانسان تواجهه باسلوب جميل غير الاسلوب
الحادي اللي بيظهر احيانا على السوشيال
ميديا والاستغفار الحادي اللي بيظهر في
السوشيال ميديا المره دي انا قلت طيب
احاول اديله بقى حل فقولت له انا شايف ان
انت وانت متصور مع الدولارات يعني مش باصص
لها يعني شكلك كده مش محتاج لها فانا عندي
حالات بتعاني من اختلال كهرباء القلب
حالات خطيره
وكانوا منزلين على صفحتي من يومين شاب
عنده 18 سنه عنده خطر التوقف القلب
المفاجئ ومحتاج جهاز صدمات كهربيه تمنه
بيتجاوز 200 الف واحيانا بيصل ال300 الف
جنيه مصري
فقال لي طيب حاول تقول لي اسماء ومستشفيات
محتاجه وبعت لي رقمك على الخاص بعت له
الرقم فاتصل بيا تاني يوم الصبح وبعد كده
اتفقنا واتقابلنا بالليل وازهر استعداده
للمشاركه في علاج الحالات وطلبنا اول حاله
مصريه بسيطه من الصعيد ما كانتش مصدقه ان
هو بيكلمها وانا كنت معاه
وان شاء الله يتم تركيب هذا الجهاز هيتكفل
هو بكل النفقات بتاعته ناس كتير يقول لك
ده مال من حرامي ازاي ما اعرفش ايه قلت
لهم بصوا يا حبايبي دكتور
هل ستكون مساعده الفنان محمد رمضان هي
مساعده واحده ام عمليه مستمره وبالتالي هو
يعني من كان يشاهد يقول والله لديه اموال
وبالدولارات اذا هي تعطيك مبلغ كبير في
اذا حولتها الى الجنيه المصري هل سيكون
هذا عمليه مستمره ولا هي مره واحده وخلاص
شو اعلامي كما يقال لا
ايه الوعد اللي هو اعلامي خالص هو على
فكره
ان هو هيقف في كل في كل هذه الحالات الوعد
قال ان في كل هذه الحالات بل هو بيفكر
وانا اقترحت عليه يعمل مؤسسه يعني تبقى
مشهره لدعم هذه الحالات بحيث يبقى بطريقه
مؤسسيه بدل ما تبقى حلاته كده عابره يبقى
في نشاط مؤسسي جمعيه خيريه تتبنى هذه
الحالات الخطيره اللي مش قادره وهو قال لي
ان امه هي اللي بتوجهه في القصه دي ان هو
بيودي للقصر العيني ويودي لابو الريش
وبيشتري حضانات وحاجات ما بيحبش يعلن يعني
الدكتور جمال ما تكلمت معه انه ليه بيعمل
هذه الحركه ليه بيحط الفلوس جنبه على
الطياره اكيد هذا سؤال بديهي اتكلمت معاه
اتكلمت معاه اتكلمت معاه وقال لي والله
العظيم انا لا اقصد استفزاز الناس لاننا
رجل من البسطاء وطلعت من البسطاء
فيها ناس كثير من البسطاء دي رسائل بيقول
دي رسائل بواجهها لناس معينين
بدليل ان هو حذف الصوره بعد كده او يعني
عمل تعديل احتفال الجزء بتاع الدولار يعني
يبقى بدنا ناخد انطباعك عن الفنان محمد
رمضان بما انك قابلته هل مثلا تفاجات بانه
استجاب لدعواتك لمساعده المرضى المحتاجين
ولا يعني كنت متوقع انه على الاغلب راح
يعمل هيك
يعني انا لما كتبت هذا المنشور ونشرته كان
عندي احساس داخلي كده ان هو يرد ما اعرفش
ليه بس جالي هذا الاحساس فهو رد بالليل
وقعدوا يبعتوا لي رسايل رد عليه بقى هو
عايز يتواصل معك جمهور كتير يعني تاني يوم
لما تواصلت معه لما قابلته هو انسان ذكي
مجتهد بيشتغل بطريقه منهجيه واخد الفن
يعني عمل احترافي مكتب وشغل بيقول لي
بذاكر وبدرس وعندي فريق عمل وبيخطط لكل
حاجه واعتقد هذه الرسائل هو بس الوحيد
اللي يعرف مين لكن هي حاجات مش انا مع
حضرتك هي مش حاجات عشوائيه ولا هبه هازرد
ولا بيعملها لا هو قاصد يوجه رسائل معينه
لكن حسب كلامه ان دي مش مقصود بيها
استفزاز الشارع
لا يكون راضي كل هذا الرضا عنها على كل
حال شكرا
نعمه بالعطاء شكرا للاسف وبدا يدخل في هذا
العطاء شكرا لك دكتور جمال شعبان طبعا
طبعا
الاختصاصيه استاذ امراض القلب وعميد معهد
القلب السابق لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات